you mentioned something there's a funny
story about we haven't talked at all
about the actual process of writing the
book is is there you guys made a bed of
some kind
yeah is this a true story is this a
completely false fact it's true
live is
she's mean when she I didn't I did not
know mean live she's like she's like a
bully she's like scary I have to have
that I have that screenshot so Liv was
FaceTiming me and she was like
she was like being intimidating I took a
screenshot and I made it my phone
background so every time I opened it I
was like ah so to give the background of
this it's because if you hadn't noticed
Tim started writing this book how many
years ago six 2016. mid 2016. right as
sort of a response to like the Trump
stuff and not not even yeah it was just
supposed to be a mini post I was like oh
I'm so like I was like I'm looking at
all these like future Tech things and I
feel it's like uneasiness like ah we're
gonna like mess up all these things why
there's like some Cloud over our society
let me just write a mini post and I open
it up to Wordpress to write a one day
little essay
and things went on politics it was gonna
be on like this feeling I had that that
like this feeling I had that
um we were our Tech was was just growing
and growing and we were becoming less
wise what what's up what's up with that
and I just wanted to write like just
like a little like little thousand word
essay on like something I think we
should pay attention to and that was the
beginning of this six year nightmare
did you anticipate also the blog post
would take a long while
I remember you saying oh I'm actually
writing this is it's turning into a
bigger thing and I was like you know
because the more we talked about
remember we were talking about I was
like oh this goes deep because I didn't
really understand the full scope of the
situation yeah like nowhere near and
Yusuf explained it I was like okay yeah
I see that and then the more we dug into
it the sort of the deeper and deeper and
deeper it went but no I did not
anticipate it would be six years let's
put it that way and when was your Ted
Talk on uh procrastination so that was
that was March of 2016 and I started
this book three months later it fell
into the biggest procrastination Hall
that I've ever fallen into oh wow the
irony isn't lost on me I mean it's like
it's I I just like I like how much cred
I have as for that Ted talk I'm like I
am legit procrastinator that is not I'm
not just saying it like but it wasn't
just that because I mean it did you know
you did intend it to start out as a blog
post but then you're like actually this
needs to maybe multiple and she does
make it into a full series you know what
I'll turn it into a book and then that's
why and and what what also what Liv
witnessed a few times and my wife has
witnessed like 30 of these is like these
these 180 epiphanies or I'll be like
I'll like I'll have a moment when I'm
and I don't know what you know sometimes
it's that there's a really good idea
sometimes it's like I'm just dreading
having to finish this the way it is and
so this Epiphany where it's like you
know what I need to start over from the
beginning and just make this like a
short like 20 little blog post list and
then I'll do that and I was like no no I
have like a new Epiphany I have to and
it's these and and yeah it's kind of
like the crazy person a little bit but
anyway can I tell the story of the the
bed go for it all right so things came
to my head when we were in we were on
vacation in Dominican Republic uh Tim
and his wife me and ego
and we were in the ocean and I remember
you'd been in the ocean for like an hour
just bobbing in there becoming it and we
got talking and we were talking about
the book and
you know you were expressing just like
this
you know the just the horror of the
situation basically or like look I just
I'm so close but there's still this and
then there's this and
um an idea popped into my head which is
that you know poker players often uh we
we will set ourselves like negative bets
you know like uh
essentially if we don't get a job done
then we have to do something we really
don't want to do so instead of having a
carrot like a really really big stick
um so I had the idea to ask Tim okay
what is the worst either organization or
individual uh that you if you had to you
know that you would loathe give a large
sum of money to and he thought about it
for a little while and he gave his
answer
and I was like all right what's your net
worth he said his net worth all right 10
of your net worth to that thing if you
don't get the draft because oh that's
sorry but just before that I'd asked him
how long like if you had a gun to your
head onto your wife's head
and you had to get the booked into a
state where you could like send off an
edit to the art to a draft to your
editor how long he's like oh I guess
like I could get it like 95 good in a
month I was like okay great in one
month's time if you do not have that
edit hand it see how scared
really scary ten percent of your net
worth is going to this thing that you
really really think is terrible but
you're forgetting the kicker go on
the kicker was that because you know
procrastinators they self-defeat that's
what they do and then Liz says I'm going
to sweeten the deal
and I am going to basically match you
and I'm going to put in I'm going to
send this like a huge amount of my own
money there if you don't do it so and
and I can't that's that would be really
bad so not only are you screwing
yourself you're screwing a friend and
she and she was like and and as your
friend because I'm your friend I will
send it I will send the money
I mean like that you know like tyranny
yeah um and um I got the draft in yeah
I know I well I could have tested this
like actually it was it was funny
because it was it was like supposed to
be by the summer solstice or whatever it
was it was like a certain date
and it was like four hours I got it in
at four and I got no I got it in at four
a.m like the next morning but then and
and and and and they were both like that
doesn't count and like it does it's
still for me it's the same day still
it's okay can you imagine how [__] in
the head you have to be yeah so like
literally technically pass the deadline
by four hours
an obscene amount of money so a thing
you loathe that's how bad the his his
sickness because I knew the hard hard
deadline I knew that there was no way
she was going to actually send that
money because it was 4am so I knew I
actually had the whole night so yeah you
know I should actually punish you and
just I should send I should send like a
nominal amount to that thing no thanks
no but uh is there some micro like
lessons from that from how to avoid
procrastination writing a book that
you've learned yes well I've learned a
lot of things I mean like first don't
take don't write like a dissertation
about like proving some Grand theory of
society because that's
really procrastinating like I I would
have been an awful PhD student for that
reason some and so like I'm gonna do
another book and it's going to be like a
bunch of short chapters that are
one-offs because that's like it just
doesn't feed into because your book is
like a giant like framework there's
Grand theories I know all through your
book I know and I learned not to do that
again I did it once I don't want to do
it again oh with the book yes
yes don't do another one it looks look
some people should it's just not for me
I I you just did it I know and it and it
almost killed me okay so that's the
first one but secondly yeah like
basically there's two ways to fix
procrastination one is you fix it's like
a picture you have a boat that's leaking
and it's not working very well you can
fix it in two ways you can get your
hammer and nails out and your boards and
actually fix the boat
or you can duct tape it for now to get
yourself across the river but it's not
actually fixed so ideally down the road
I have repaired whatever kind of bizarre
mental illness that I have that makes me
procrastinate in a very like I just
don't self-defeat in this way anymore
but in the meantime
I Can duct tape the boat by bringing
what I call the Panic monster into the
situation via things like this and this
scary person and having external
pressure to have external pressure of
some kind is critical for me uh it's
it's yes I don't have the muscle to do
the work I need to do without external
pressure by the way I live is there a
possible future where you write a book
and Meanwhile by the way huge
procrastinator that's the funny thing
about this yeah no yeah I mean how long
did your last video take oh my God is
there advice would you do you give to
Liv how to get the videos done faster
well it would be the same exact thing I
mean actually I can give good
procrastination advice Panic monster
um well we should do it together it
should be like we have this date but
right you know it's it's um we said she
just do another bet I have to have my
script done by this time yes yeah if I
go to get the third part out because
then you'll actually do it um and um and
and it's not the thing is the time in
but it's like if you if you could take
three weeks on a video and instead you
take 10 weeks it's not like oh well I've
also I'm having more fun in those times
you're the whole 10 weeks
bad so you're just you're just having a
bad time and you're getting less work
done and less work out and it's not like
you're enjoying your personal life it's
bad for you for your relationships it's
bad for your your own you keep doing it
anyway yeah well a lot of people why do
people uh have troubles keeping a diet
right yeah primitive mind why'd you
point at me
that's offensive what's your
procrastination weakness do you have one
everything everything right now
everything has everything preparing for
a conversation I had your book amazing
book I really enjoyed it I started
reading it
I was like this is awesome it's so
awesome that I'm going to save it when
I'm behind the computer and can take
notes like good notes of course that
resulted in like last minute everything
everything I'm doing in my life not
everyone's like that you know people
self-defeat in different ways some
people don't have this particular
problem Adam Grant is that he calls
himself a pre-crastinator where he gets
an assignment he will go home and do it
until it's done and handed it which is
also not necessarily good you know it's
like you're rushing it either way but
it's better but some people have the
opposite thing
um where they will
um the the the the the the looming
deadline makes them so anxious that they
go and fix it right and the
procrastinator I think has a similar
anxiety but it they they solve it in a
totally different way well they don't
solve it they just live with the anxiety
right right they just living things that
now I think there's a even bigger group
of people so there's these people that
Adam grants there's people like me and
then there's people who have a healthy
relationship with deadlines but they're
still part of a bigger group of people
that actually they they um
they need a deadline there to do
something so they actually they they
still are motivated by a deadline and as
soon as you have all the things in life
that don't have a deadline like working
out and like working on that album you
wanted to write they don't do anything
either so there's actually like that's
why procrastination is a much bigger
problem Than People realize because it's
not just the funny last second people
it's anyone who
um actually can't get things done that
don't have a deadline
you dedicate your book quote to Tannis
who never planned on being married to
someone who would spend six years
talking about his book on politics but
here we are uh what's the secret to a
successful relationship with the
procrastinator
that's maybe for both of you
um well I think the the first most
important thing you already started with
a political answer I could tell okay go
ahead no no the first and most important
thing is because people who don't
procrastinate if you don't it's like you
will they people in the instinct is to
judge it as like uh
that's either either just think think
they're just being like a loser or
they're taking it they'll take it
personally you know uh and instead to
see this as like this is this is a uh
some form of addiction or some form of
um ailment you know they're not just
being a dick right like they have a
problem and so so some compassion but
then also maybe finding that line where
you can you know maybe apply some tough
love some middle ground on the other
hand you might say that you know you
don't want the the significant other
relationship where it's like they're
into one nagging you maybe that's you
don't want them even being part of that
and I think maybe it's you know better
to have a live do it instead right
having someone who can like create the
infrastructure where they aren't the
direct stick you need a bit of carrot
and stick right maybe they can be the
person who keeps reminding them of the
carrot
and then they set up the friend group to
be the stick and then that keeps your
relationship yeah in a good steak like
looming in the background that's your
friend group okay at the beginning of
the conversation we talked about how all
of human history can be presented as a
thousand page book
uh what are you excited about for the
how do you say that first page
uh so the next 250 years
what are you most excited about I'm most
excited about
um have you read the Fable of the Dragon
okay well it's an allegory for death and
it's you know Nick Bostrom and he talks
about the he Compares death to a dragon
that eats 60 million people or whatever
the number is every year and you just
every year we Shepherd those people up
and they feed him to the dragon and that
there's a Stockholm syndrome when we say
that's just a lot of man and that's what
we have to do and anyone who says maybe
we should try to beat the dragon they
get called Vain and narcissistic
um but someone who
tries to someone who goes does chemo no
one calls them Vayner narcissistic they
say they're they're you know good good
for you right you're a hero you're
you're fighting fighting the good fight
so I think there's some disconnect here
and I think that if we can
get out of that Stockholm syndrome and
realize that death is just the machine
that the human physical machine failing
and that there's no law of nature that
says you can't with enough technology
um uh repair the machine and keep it
going until no one I don't think anyone
wants to live forever people think they
do no one does but until people are
ready and I think when we hit a world
where we can ex we have enough Tech that
we can continue to keep the human
machine alive until the person says I'm
done I'm ready I think we will look back
and we will think that anything before
that time that'll be the real A.D BC you
know we'll look back at BC before the
big advancement and it'll seem so sad
and so heartbreaking barbaric and people
say I can't believe
that humans like us had to live with
that when they lost loved ones and they
they died before they were ready I think
that's the ultimate achievement but we
need to stop
criticizing and smearing people who you
talk about it so you think where that's
actually doable in the next 250 years
okay a lot happens in 250 years
especially when technology really
exponentially yeah
and you think humans will be around
versus AI complete takes over yeah I
mean look The Optimist in me and maybe
the stupid kind of 2023 person in me
says yeah of course we'll we'll make it
we'll we'll figure it out but you know
I mean we are going into
um a crate you know I have a friend who
knows as much about the future as anyone
I know I mean he's really he's a big
investor and you know future Tech and he
um he's really on the puzzle things and
he just says the future's going to be
weird that's what he says if you're just
gonna be weird and it's it's good don't
look at your the last few Decades of
your life and apply that for it and say
that's just what life is like no no it's
going to be weird and different
well some of my favorite things in this
world are weird and speaking of which
it's good to uh have this conversation
it's good to have you as friends this
was an incredible one thanks for coming
back and thanks for talking with me a
bunch more times this is awesome thank
you Lex thank you